[Musica]
buon pomeriggio oggi vi voglio parlare
di un sogno il sogno della cura dei sani
naturalmente quando dico cura non
intendo terapia anzi è proprio il
contrario ma lo intendo nel senso di
battiato
io mi prendo cura di cura di te mi
interessa qualcosa al chiar diremmo in
inglese ma in effetti se ci pensiamo
quando parliamo di questo argomento
l'organo istituzionale che si occupa
dell'argomento si chiama ministero della
salute e non si chiama ministero delle
malattie ma malgrado ciò anche noi
quando pensiamo alla nostra salute
ci immaginiamo subito la farmacia
all'ospedale che sala chirurgica
l'ambulatorio e pensiamo alle malattie e
pensiamo che le malattie siano tutte
diverse le malattie cardiovascolari i
tumori le malattie neurodegenerative
siamo nella situazione in cui era
tolomeo quando ha pensato che la terra
fosse al centro dell'universo e che
tutto girasse attorno alla terra
poi è venuto copernico e ha convinto
tutti che non era così ma che era il
sole al centro e quindi ha cambiato
affatto quella che chiamiamo una
rivoluzione copernicana
allora oggi ci troviamo nella medicina
con l'esigenza col desiderio di fare una
rivoluzione copernicana al posto della
malattia
vogliamo mettere al centro della
medicina la persona l'uomo ma quando
pensiamo all uomo abbiamo una tradizione
tale che pensiamo immediatamente all
uomo sofferente all uomo malato come
questo incappucciato della processione
del giovedì santo che si svolge a
lanciano in abruzzo e noi ci immaginiamo
che da questo dal modello dell'uomo
malato possiamo ricavare delle
informazioni
tutti lì per tutta una serie di altre
persone che come vediamo sembrano tutte
uguali e per cui il modello del malato
va bene
in realtà se corriamo gli incappucciati
in un momento in cui non hanno il
cappuccio
ci rendiamo conto che sono l'uno diverso
dall'altro e che quindi questo modello
non va bene
voglio quindi utilizzare qui una frase
famosa di don milani che diceva
l'obbedienza non è più una virtù
io voglio dire in medicina l'uguaglianza
non è più una virtù
non siamo tutti i diabetici non siamo
tutti ipertesi vogliamo vedere le cose
in un modo diverso certo se fossimo come
questi ombrelloni di rimini tutti male
sarebbe una casa molto più semplice ma
in realtà la nostra situazione è più
vicina a quello che voi vedete adesso in
questa in questa immagine ma davanti a
questa confusione davanti a questa
complessità della della situazione degli
uomini che cosa possiamo fare una
quindicina di anni fa con il mio gruppo
di ricerca che operava in molise abbiamo
pensato di fare di cambiare un po la
prospettiva è di fare uno studio che dal
nome stesso dal titolo stesso del
progetto moli sani sottolinea indica
chiaramente che siamo interessati di più
alla salute che alla malattia e siamo
interessati di più a capire cosa c'è
prima cosa c'è all'origine del benessere
dell'uomo
abbiamo sorteggiato come diceva brecht
stamattina abbiamo sorteggiato 30 paesi
in molise e siamo andati a chiedere al
sindaco la lista dei residenti e in ogni
paese abbiamo preso un numero di persone
abbiamo sorteggiato
di persone proporzionale al numero degli
abitanti e alla fine abbiamo preso 25
mila persone
era una cifra veramente che all'inizio
mi ha impressionato e abbiamo pensato
adesso vediamo come questa popolazione è
però subito ci siamo resi conto che non
valeva la pena di sapere quanti tumori
c'erano quante malattie cardiovascolari
abbiamo pensato di andare un pochino più
alle radici e ci siamo immaginati che le
malattie che a noi sembrano così diverse
in realtà se andiamo a scavare sotto
vediamo che sono come degli alberi che
hanno delle radici o comune o comunque
che si intersecano molto allora il
nostro interesse si è spostato dalle
foglie dai rami si è spostato sulle
radici
vi faccio qualche esempio di che cosa
abbiamo trovato in questa indagine una
delle radici che è alla base di quegli
alberi che abbiamo visto è
l'infiammazione
allora noi sappiamo l'infiammazione ci
immaginiamo una febbre altissima
un dolore alle ginocchia che non ci fa
camminare
delle artriti e artrosi tutto tutto
quello che vi potete immaginare ma
questo è già qualcosa che è successo
noi non vogliamo fare una medicina di
guardia e ladri che succede che prima
aspettiamo che i ladri facciano un
operazione
e poi le guardie li inseguono e noi
facciamo uguale
aspettiamo prima che si sviluppi una
malattia prima che si sviluppi e si
manifesti un infiammazione e poi gli
andiamo dietro cerchiamo di curarla
non è così vogliamo vedere piuttosto
qualche cosa che rassomiglia meglio a
questa immagine non ci interessa la
parte dell'iceberg che si vede
sì lo vedono tutti lo può vedere la
medicina tradizionale
noi vogliamo andare più sotto vogliamo
andare a studiare a capire cosa c'è
nella parte nascosta dell'iceberg
e questo vi assicuro è un'impresa molto
affascinante qualche esempio
questa infiammazione che non è appunto
il dolore la febbre può essere misurata
in modo che abbiamo elaborato nei nostri
laboratori e chiamiamo infiammazione
subclinica tutti noi qui abbiamo un
infiammazione subclinica ma nessuno di
noi lo sa neanche io
ma se andiamo a misurare in una
popolazione come molisani questi
parametri ci accorgiamo che c'è una
diversità nessuno se ne rende conto però
andiamo abbiamo potuto vedere che man
mano aumenta man mano che aumenta questa
infiammazione subclinica aumenta niente
meno che il rischio di morire
quindi noi camminiamo tranquilli
portando dentro di noi un infiammazione
subclinica
che determina favorisce quello che sarà
il nostro rischio di morire è una cosa è
veramente affascinante allora uno subito
dice dammi farmaco che voglio ridurre
questa infiammazione no il farmaco viene
dopo
fa parte di quella medicina che noi non
vogliamo fare che cosa possiamo fare per
ridurre nella nostra vita di persone
sane questa infiammazione
allora abbiamo potuto studiare e capire
che mangiare in modo mediterraneo delle
nostre parti è abbastanza frequente
aderire alla dieta mediterranea riduce
questa infiammazione di cui nessuno se
ne accorge ma neanche noi mangiando alla
dieta mediterranea frutta verdura olio
d'oliva un pochino di pesce e così via
nessuno si accorge che mangiando si
riduce l'infiammazione
sono tutte cose che vanno sotto
l'iceberg ma determinano in maniera
importante quello che è adesso la nostra
salute e quello che potrà essere un
domani il rischio di ammalarci o
addirittura di morire allora abbiamo
voluto verificare se la dieta
mediterranea riduce questa infiammazione
subclinica cosa fa poi nella realtà e
come vedete riduce la mortalità per
malattie cardiovascolari ma anche la
mortalità totale per tutte le cause
quindi è una cosa di interessante che se
uno segue questo tipo di alimentazione
riduce qualche cosa che non vediamo ma
riduce anche qualche cosa che si può
sperimentare che è la mortalità per le
malattie più diffuse che abbiamo oggi
che sono le malattie cardiovascolari
però evidentemente non è soltanto la
dieta mediterranea
noi sappiamo tutti che è bene che è bene
non fumare che bene
camminare fare attività fisica che è
bene controllare il peso se mettiamo
insieme tutte queste buone abitudini e
poi andiamo a misurare nei dieci anni di
osservazione ci stiamo seguendo che
stiamo facendo su questa popolazione di
molisani
vediamo che i moli same che non seguono
questi stili di vita hanno una curva di
mortalità che è quella rossa in alto che
è molto più alta molto più pericolosa di
chi invece vivendo nello stesso ambiente
ovviamente calcolando tutte le variabili
la variazione qui sono solo gli stili di
vita a un rischio un turno di mortalità
che è molto più bassa quindi non c'è
bisogno di andare in ospedale
non c'è bisogno di pensare alle farmacie
non c'è bisogno di pensare ai farmaci
noi possiamo controllare la nostra
salute e anche prevedere prevenire delle
cose di che temiamo in maniera che è
molto più vicina all'essere sani e
all'essere malati allora dopo aver visto
queste cose eravamo molto contenti e
molto soddisfatti
poi siamo andati a guardare un pochino
più da vicino e ci siamo resi conto che
la dieta mediterranea non è uguale per
tutti non fa bene a tutti
indistintamente
per esempio chi ha studiato di più ha
più vantaggio dalla dieta mediterranea e
poi diventerà perché non lo sappiamo
ancora bene però sappiamo perché
l'abbiamo studiato che chiesto chi ha un
grado di istruzione superiore legge
meglio le etichette e più critico e
segue meno le notizie false che i
giornali e la televisione ci propinano
sulla salute
ogni giorno ogni giorno ci sono anche
persone che hanno dei canali televisivi
che dicono una serie di sciocchezze
quando uno è colto più ha sviluppato un
sistema critico per resistere a questo
tipo di mala informazione
el altra cosa e ci siamo accorti che non
solo il medico ma l'agenzia delle
entrate gioca un ruolo importante nella
nostra salute
la gran parte dei voli sani hanno
risposta alla domanda sul reddito
familiare
guardandoci bene se potevamo essere
degli agenti delle tasse camuffati da un
camice e quindi abbiamo potuto studiare
e valutare che il reddito è più
importante del colesterolo
noi tutti vogliamo misurarci il
colesterolo ma il reddito familiare il
reddito personale estremamente
importante perché vi faccio un semplice
esempio la dieta mediterranea è
caratterizzata da tante cose l'olio
extravergine di oliva
allora noi nei questionari diciamo lei
signora consuma l'olio essere generosi
allora un punto a favore e lei consuma
l'olio extravergine origo si siede un
punto a favore poi seconda domanda
quanto costa mediamente una bottiglia di
olio che le copre 14 euro costa una
bottiglia mediamente 4 euro all'ora
e vero che tutte e due seguono la dieta
mediterranea è vero che tutte e due
condiscono l'insalata con l'olio
extravergine di oliva ma capite che la
differenza enorme quindi anche
all'interno della dieta mediterranea
l'uguaglianza non è più una virtù
e non basta più dire che la dieta
mediterranea fa bene bisogna definirne
la qualità l'origine capire tutte queste
cose per poter avere un'idea di come va
e come può andare la nostra salute o il
rischio di ammalarci è l'ultima cosa che
abbiamo visto che ci sta molto
interessando siamo in una società che
invecchia
quindi stiamo diventando tutti più
vecchi e quindi
la vecchiaia l'invecchiamento è
certamente un problema che ci interessa
molto allora abbiamo scoperto nei moli
sani che non è tanto importante
l'età che deriva dai nostri passaporti
dalla carta d'identità che ognuno di noi
sa ma l'età biologica cioè l'età che
deriva da una serie di parametri che noi
stiamo elaborando per cercare di
definire meglio che cos'è questa età
biologica l'età biologica corrisponde
meglio al rischio di ammalarsi e alla
possibilità di tenere bene la nostra la
nostra salute
basta quindi con una medicina che si
accontenta di misurare la pressione
misurare il colesterolo la glicemia
l'esame delle urine
vogliamo una medicina che indaghi l'uomo
che indaghi la persona in tutte le sue
caratteristiche
nelle sue passioni nelle sue letture nei
suoi viaggi dove abita come viaggia qual
è il suo sì la sua situazione socio
economica
e così anche io anche noi come diogene
andiamo in giro in mezzo alla gente a
cercare l'uomo a cercare la persona
fisica dell'individuo
in realtà a me non interessa molto che
sia più sano o meno malato mi interessa
che sia più felice e mi interessa che
abbia trovato un senso alla propria vita
e alla propria morte
la ricerca continua vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]